back to las vegas now whether you're
gifting mom or your significant other
with jewelry we suggest you make sure
you're giving real gems to your family
gym okay certified gemologist appraiser
and owner of huntington jewelers jenny
oh is here to help us okay because you
know i feel like i want to cover my
necklace just in case but
you know it's important that you give
real jewelry real gems to your to your
loved ones but first and foremost you
know how did you become a gemologist
that's such a cool job i just want to
know you know what i'm born and raised
here in fabulous las vegas and i was
going to community college and i was
working at a dry cleaner and you know
what all my friends had way cool jobs
spago belmont mgm and i was like i have
got to have a better job here and
literally opened the phone book up one
day and was like oh i like jewelry let
me try that and i started with kay
jewelers when i was 19 and the rest is
history now you're here i'm so glad i
asked you that you guys see look at that
anything can happen okay let's get into
the test because you're gonna put me to
the test to see what's real what's fake
and you'll explain what makes it real
what makes it fake you got it so let's
start with me because i have like a
couple pieces on okay i want you to look
at the
blue and white gems okay what's real
what's fake oh my gosh i don't want to
offend that's okay you're not offending
i got these cute little signs okay i'm
going for
if you want to say the earrings are the
earrings are real
real hey that's right okay they're
really fabulous my mom has taught me
well okay um but there's some i'm going
to say i'm going to say this
yeah this is fake yeah you found it you
found it
so so let's talk about what makes
something real and what makes something
fake what do we need to look out for
well there's a lot of synthetics out
there there are different metals
there's a variety of alloys that are
combined to
look like maybe a platinum or a white
gold there's something we can compare
here well right here yeah i mean this is
it right here i also have you know a
couple rings i mean we can you can pick
the next and we can dive into something
a little bit deeper i'm going to say
that
this
this is fake
this is actually real dang
dang
oh
that's okay it doesn't feel good to get
it wrong this is the one that is fake
okay okay this guy right here okay so
maybe how do we tell because they look
the same well you know what if it was
easy to do everybody would be doing
that's
and we have a series of tests that we
we're like little inspector gadgets okay
okay so there's some machinery there's
machinery we for metal we have an x-ray
machine that's actually used for the
mining industry and so
there was an older version of testing or
we would scratch the metal on a little
stone and run acid over it but now like
you know something like this is heavily
plated right
but underneath it's like brass you know
what i'm saying and so
any gemstone as gemologist we're taught
to know like it could be glass or
plastic
what kind of series of tests
gemologically can we do
to rule that out okay okay we have to
wrap up so just really quick how can
people visit you at huntington jewelers
well you can look at our website we have
a great social media as well at
huntingtonjewelers.com
we are right across from mercedes-benz
on west sahara and we've been there for
23 years we've been in vegas 70 years
and we got a whole assortment of goods i
love it real gems jason welcome to you
thank you so much oh we'll be right back
jc sorry